What I am doing.
And what I do on a professional basis every day is I take the meme culture
world. The meme world, prequel meme, star Wars means, I mean,
some of the best memes out there, star Wars memes,
and you apply that to politics.
And you were able to get an intersectional point where you can get a young
kid or some young person who might know star Wars,
but doesn't quite understand what's going on with a beach man.
And you can frame it the world for them based on star Wars,
actually bring them into the political process, which is very important.
I'm Dave Rubin and according to the Wikipedia editors,
this is the Rubin report as always guys make sure that you're subscribed to our
channel by clicking subscribe over there and clicking that notification bell.
And more importantly,
joining me today is the chief creative officer for turning point USA
and me maker. Extraordinary Eddie Johnson. Fantastic.
This feels very overdue, man. I don't know.
How has this taken so long to happen? You're a busy guy. You're a busy guy.
You're a busy guy going around the world. Jordan Peterson. It's like a,
you know, like cut his IQ in half. You got me. Yeah.
You're half of Peterson's brain. Let's vary room, temperature, IQ room,
temperature room temperature. Well, I have one of you on for a while.
I'm glad we're finally doing this. And before, you know,
normally when I started interview, I kind of asked people, their background,
a little loop framing of the interview, but I thought first,
what we're going to do is we're just going to throw to this video that you just
put up on Instagram. This is you going to,
this is outside of the impeachment hearings. Yes.
Outside of the impeachment hearings.
You're asking questions about politics and Trump and impeachment all
through the lens of a little movie called star Wars.
Here we go.
Hey everyone.
Benny Johnson here at the United States Capitol where the impeachment trial of
president Trump is ongoing.
The Capitol has tens of leftist protestors gathered at it.
Calling for the impeachment of president Trump. Specifically,
we're asking them if star Wars references about president Trump are
worthy of having him be impeached.
Um, Senate.
We're going to see if these leftist protesters believe that the president should
be impeached. For instance, of killing a fictional general, general grievance.
Hello?
I can't wait to hear what they have to say. Let's go for it.
Many people felt a disturbance in the forest when general grievance was killed.
What do you think about the killing of general grievous and why? You know,
was it right or wrong? Okay. Uh, nobody was saying that, uh,
he was a good person.
There've been a lot of bad people in, uh, in a world. Uh, and, uh,
uh, we have laws, everything. What we'll do.
Is our mail that they shouldn't be.
Then July. I love them up here.
With new XYZ technology though. There's no,
there's no telling what we can accomplish. I mean, you can get anyone anywhere.
Yes, yes, absolutely.
[Inaudible].
Uh, do you think that it was right or not right to kill general grievous.
There's clearly an assassination. I don't think so.
People were saying that a thermal detonator was used for the assassination and
these are very dangerous weapons. Do you have anything to say on that?
You seem to care a lot about this.
Technically I can't tell you.
I'm not sure about that yet.
[inaudible].
This is just like the kind of music that was
being sang at MOS. Eisley Cantina.
It's beautiful.
Uh, general grievous was killed by the administration by Trump.
They were saying that was illegal. Do you,
do you believe in those kinds of killings or do you not? We have a rule of law.
If that rule of law says, if I think you're a bad guy,
then I should be able to kill you. Right? That's not our rule of law.
I killed them. I killed them off.
The rule of laws. If I think you're a bad guy,
I'm supposed to take you to trial and prove that you are a bad guy.
That is our rule of law in the United States of America.
You can't, he must have.
And trial. Apparently he was killed with a thermal detonator.
This is like a lot concerning to a lot of people. And, uh,
the rule of law either we have it and we need to live by it,
both the citizens and our government, or we don't.
And we don't give a crap one way or the other.
My Lord is done.
All right. So that's just a small portion of this video that you put out there.
And I think now my audience understands why I wanted to throw that before we do
anything else here. Now that one gentleman at the end did make a good point.
Should we not have taken general grievance in and put him on trial? I mean,
he was the leader of the separatist army.
He had just taken over from count dude, count dugu who's a horrible human being.
It's a good point. Yeah. I mean, it's true. I, I,
who knows. I mean, if it was the Obama administration,
definitely would have taken him out with a drone would have never seen it
happening. You know,
it could have even been an American citizen would have been boom,
Gerald Green was gone when you do these videos.
Cause I know most people watching them are going, Oh, come on.
He must've had to go to a thousand different people to get the five, 10 guys.
First five people, not a single, I kept asking him about general grievous.
And you can see in the video, I keep like pushing him.
Like people felt a disturbance in the force.
It's,
it's very much a dark side to have this technology with a thermal detonator and
XYZ technology to kill this general. No one, nothing.
I even say later in the video that Trump should just execute an order,
66 and dissolve the Senate.
And then he can just get rid of this impeachment fiasco.
What does this tell you about these people before we get to the star Wars
element of it and why star Wars memes really do work well?
What does this tell you about?
A lot of the activists that are out there and people that are, you know,
purporting to know everything about politics.
I'm not even talking about these five people specifically with them,
but these people that are just out there protesting all the time and then
whenever you see them challenge, you know, Crowder is really good at this.
They just suddenly no, no nothing. Yeah.
Okay. So the purpose of the video,
like this is never to actually make fun of anyone.
What I'm trying to do is to show that there is a bankruptcy when it comes to the
understanding of why we are impeaching this president,
why do are these people actually out there protesting every person in the video
is protesting for Trump's impeachment yet,
even when asked if they should impeach Trump for killing general grievous,
which was my question,
should we impeach Trump for killing a fictional star Wars villain? They said,
yeah.
And so what I am doing and what I do on a professional basis every day is I take
the meme culture world, the meme world, prequel meme, star Wars means, I mean,
some of the best memes out there star Wars means,
and you apply that to politics and you were able to get an intersectional
point where you can get a young kid or some young person who might know star
Wars, but doesn't quite understand what's going on with a beach man.
And you can frame it the world for them based on star Wars and actually bring
them into the political process, which is very important. So.
What is it about star Wars?
Because I mean the hell out of star Wars probably only second to you, right?
And there's something particularly about the prequels that the memes just,
you know, how does a democracy die with thunderous applause?
And I am the Senate and all of those lines,
they seem so powerful right now. And it's like, what,
what do you think it is about star Wars specifically that leads to this where
other movies, you can mean some things from other movies,
but not like the endless amount from star Wars that just fuels right for the
moment all the time.
Star Wars was, if you go,
if you rewind the clock back to George Lucas,
he based the empire on Nazis and he based the rebellion on fighting
Nazis. And so for people like us, particularly,
you were able to find these moral threads that you can pull out of the basic
star Wars story, the evil of oppressive,
overarching brutalist government, uh, how it tries to squash hope,
how hope must rise in order to fight that greatest evil,
which is an oppressive, overarching massive,
usually by emergency powers government that can take over all of our lives.
And that is the, the truth that this was based on.
I think it hits at a human truth,
a truth that goes all the way back to our founding and much of the Renaissance.
Good. That comes from the idea that man is man, and man wants freedom.
And man has liberties that should not be corrupted and oppressed by a
government. It's funny because.
Even though you're doing it in a funny way, there,
we could talk about the idea that should the jet. I have captured grievous.
He was the leader of the separatist army, right? So he was an insurgent,
but should they have been allowed to just kill him as,
as obiwan did or should they have captured him and taken him for trial?
That actually is an interesting philosophical point that we debate all the time,
because that's, to your point that when we killed Soleimani,
everyone was saying, well, you can't just kill the guy.
You have to bring them in for a trial or the rest of it. That, I mean,
that really all does add up to why.
Yes, correct.
Memes are a piece of non-corporate
non-establishment media
imagery that reflects a moment in culture and reflect something that we're all
going through and explains it in a very simple and shareable way.
Think for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics instead of
nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.